speaking of things i've been watching
it's not a tv show
or a movie or an anime oh okay i i was
watching a particular live stream
[Applause]
women women always say men don't have
feelings
i definitely had feelings when i was
watching uh coco's graduation live
stream dude that was [ __ ] insane man
that was nuts i think i saw like on new
on the news
uh that i think it was like on like
internet news i mean not the tv news i
saw on the internet news that i think
that ended up being i think the
seventh highest life stream of all time
yeah i saw that as well she i think she
capped at 480 000 people watching her
live
yeah during the concert bit she it was
like 480 000. i was kind of wondering if
he was going to break 500.
come on come on you can do it sims come
on
i believe in you it was it was nice
because i was watching that live
and there's some parts the chat was
going
so fast that it was literally lagging
the stream yeah yeah
i was yeah it was crazy i was
occasionally popping in and just seeing
what was going on
yeah yeah i mean i didn't care much
about like the whole like idol
side of things because i've never really
cared about the whole whole live vital
side of things or whatever but like yeah
yeah there were parts where i was just
like getting a little emotional
honestly honestly the same because i uh
i couldn't watch it live
because uh we were doing something at
the time but i watched like the uh
recording afterwards and uh honestly it
was like i
i'm as as i've said i've watched less
youtubers now than i did last year but
man it was getting emotional at some
point yeah holy [ __ ] but i cuz i
honestly think this is an
end of an era for hollow life because i
think hololive
owes coco so [ __ ] much oh yeah right
because
she is basically the sole reason why hot
alive is as
big internationally yeah she's basically
the reason why a lot of english exists
yeah right
exactly um and i feel like to me it was
like the end of an era for hollow life
because
you know she's done so much for the
company and now she's just not there
anymore and
you know i feel like she did move at her
own accord which is
which is happy that no big like
controversy happens
to make her move it was fully it's fully
respectable that she was just like
i kind of just don't want to be here
again or for whatever reason
which just made it even more bittersweet
because i'm happy that she made the
decision to move on and do whatever she
wants to do now
but you know it is and she went out with
a [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
like i saw those super chats bro it was
it was i don't want to think about how
much money she made
yeah and then also i mean she clearly
enjoys doing other stuff
on the side so why not right like you
can bring a massive audience over with
you
yeah if you do a show like that like
people of course go check out what
you're doing next
yeah it was a brilliant idea as well
like yeah yeah exactly
because i mean i i think honestly coco
in terms of just like looking at
each challenge as content creators i do
think she is genuinely one of the most
talented content creators in holla live
and that's just
and i mean if she wasn't then she
wouldn't have had the success that she
did internationally i think also can i
say
massive brain idea that she pre-recorded
like the interview sections and put
english subtitles yeah yeah yeah i was
like that is so gigabrain because i was
like wait how are they
how are they subtitles i was like is
there just like a trap
the jojo event panel people are like how
are they doing this
that's possible at first i was just i
just thought that was like some [ __ ]
light speed translator
i got this boys i got this yeah i was
like that's so gigabyte because she
clearly knows
how like i reckon her international fan
base was just as big as a japanese fan
base yeah so it's like why not get both
of them at the same time
yeah it's so gigabyte i mean i feel like
that's why the live stream was
partly how it broke so many records
right it's just because it wasn't just
the japanese audience watching i mean it
wasn't
only just gonna be a japanese audience
watching it anyway but there's there was
always going to be a big part of the
audience that just
didn't get what was going on and i was
like should should i cry now is it
or is it that's like crying is it good
is it the goodbye time right now
right now right now it's oh okay but no
like thanks to the subtitles everyone
can get involved in it so it was just
like a five head move
yeah absolutely yeah and he's sad what
what did you what did you think i didn't
really watch it i mean i was watching it
occasionally i was like yeah this is
pretty cool yeah it was all right i mean
again like i've mentioned before i don't
really like i'm not like a
massive simp of any of them i don't know
if that's a derogatory term
banned on twitch i don't particularly
like watch
a lot of them i know will you collab
with them yeah it's different though
yeah so i you know to me it was like all
right i mean this is it it was cool like
it was an epic show yeah
i saw epic sorry i can't say that
without being sarcastic
epic it was clearly just an amazing
production and props to the team man it
was uh
i mean if you're gonna go out why not
[ __ ] do it like that yeah yeah like
[ __ ] it out
because like i i feel like um what was
what was i going to say again i
i feel like they did really put on a
good show and it was it was going out
with a bang and if there was a way that
she was going to go out this was the
best way to go out
yeah um i completely agree with her
creatively and i hope the best for
her future endeavors because i would
choose the same thing i would choose
to go out with a bang rather than just
like physically yeah
yeah absolutely especially if you're not
happy with what you're doing right it's
inevitable that it's gonna
it's gonna happen so yeah it was it was
the right move i think it just really
now puts into perspective i'm just like
who's the next one that's gonna go if
there is gonna be another one well yeah
it's an interesting thing because i feel
that because it was so new and so fresh
the idea of
people are going to leave it was so odd
right but i guess
you can't always just people people
joining right it's going to get to a
point where there's going to be as many
people leaving as there is joining i do
yeah that has to be that's the thing
right it's like i do wonder because
coco was the first whole life talent to
leave hollow life on her own accord
right
like i'm just thinking like i'm sure of
we know yeah
but like i'm sure like her announcing
that she was going to leave probably
planted in some of the other talents
heads being like oh
you can just you can you can do that you
can leave you can just
quit yeah well yeah i think the most
interesting thing
for me personally about youtubers is
like the politics of it all oh yeah yeah
it seems like there is like a lot of
stuff
on the jp side yeah and it's just really
entertaining
watching it because everyone's like no
you can't turn left
you die you have to turn right yeah you
know and everyone's like freaking out
it's really like thousands of people
backseating it's very fun watching this
kind of stuff you know and the
the the rules and all the politics it's
very it's like you know it's like people
turn
anime into uh game of thrones sometimes
yeah
and it's hella exciting i love watching
it i'm like a spectator you know
in that sense and uh i think that this
bri
yeah this does ask the question of is
this going to be a normal thing
how will it be dealt with what impact
will this have on youtubing as a whole
who knows yeah i'm going to be watching
on the sidelines having a great day
because there was because recently
there's been a couple of like
bigger uh niji sanjiv youtubers as well
that have like
left on their own accord and it's like i
feel it's like
slowly starting to become a thing of
like just especially the bigger creators
kind of realizing that oh if i stay in a
in a you know this kind of like uh
agency
then i'm kind of limited to what i can
you can only be of each other
right and it's only up until they get to
a certain point that they realize like
oh
i if i just leave i have so many more
opportunities that i can try out for
myself without being like restricted i
mean it's
it's like it's like a catch 22 right
because i feel like you know without
um without saying anything too private
like you know
i feel like coco was one of the few who
could who had established herself like
outside
you know and i feel like especially with
how big she is
she she can do whatever the hell she
wants you know and
be able to establish yourself but i feel
like with especially with some hololive
youtubers
they're only known for being hololive
youtube sure true right
and it's like a catch-22 because they
could leave whenever they want
but if they leave what would they be
saying
goodbye to you know would you know
they'd basically have to like build
themselves
up from the ground up again yeah and
with
the v tubing scene being how it is they
can't really build up
their other any other kind of thing that
they do outside of hollow life right
because
that's they kind of just feel like
casting right well it's it's it's like
you know it's the secrecy behind the v2
and there is a reason for it
but at the same time if there is a
youtuber who does want to talk about
their other lives then they just can't
with the platform they have and
they're just going to be known as this
whole live youtuber
rather than anything else they may
potentially want to be sure
which is why if i think if we saw
someone leave a heart a v2 agency
to become another youtuber i feel like
that's like the wrong idea
yeah but the whole point is to expand
you know and do something else yeah
otherwise why did you leave yeah yeah um
you just made you
just made a heart over on yourself right
right right and also like you know
uh obviously hololive is is big and
there's uh you know there's other
agencies and it's just oh my god there's
[ __ ] so many now yeah
i what i find interesting now as a
content creator
is that you know in youtube and twitch
there's like there's
there's a like there's like hierarchies
right like of like
your size yeah right and and like with
with uh youtube and twitch where you
you're kind of on your own you kind of
just do your own thing you you do
you want if you're with an agency
there's kind of expectations of you to
perform or do anything right so you know
when you start bringing in talent and
you keep bringing in talent
what happens when you have too much too
many people and the market is
oversaturated and it's partially
your agency right yeah so what if you
have too many youtubers and maybe you're
some of the youtubers aren't doing too
well struggling a little bit how do you
handle that
like what do you do do you like just
leave it you just see now that
that's where i'm getting that's where
i'm like interested in seeing how they
handle that because that'll really show
what their mindset is right on how to
handle situations because i think
currently whole i have now has like less
than
30 no around 30 i'd say i think there's
more than that right what
well yeah actually if you include en and
i n
and uh and id and then languages in
future yeah let's let's say yeah okay
let's let's guess like probably around
like less than 50 i reckon which is
still a lot
right but then you have agencies like
ninja sanji that have literally
hundreds right right and like you know
do you if you're
an agency where you're like okay you
know if we want to keep bringing in new
talent we got to hire more staff we
can't afford to do it because not
everyone's pulling in the same numbers
not everyone can be the
number one yeah obviously what do you do
do you start cutting off talent
if so how does that look publicly right
i mean i feel like that's a lose-lose
right because you can't just cut off
talon because no matter what if you cut
talon off
the fact their fan base is gonna [ __ ]
make a lot of noise and you don't come
out
looking good at all um and i guess
i don't know it's it's interesting but i
don't think there's just so many
problems and
challenges that i think will arise yeah
because we haven't seen them yet because
it's so new
yeah but i think down the line gonna be
coming into these things and i'm just
interested to see how the fan bases will
handle
all these things coming out because
they're going to happen at some point i
mean right now
the v tubing scene it's kind of like the
wild west yeah it is it's the new thing
and it's just starting to establish
itself now
like it's it's only getting it's only
getting to the point now where
you know we had the massive explosion in
2020 and now
we're kind of seeing what the youtube
scene v tubing scene sorry it's gonna be
really like in 2021 and above
uh because you know right now coco
leaving that's
that's a massive creator on the platform
and arguably
she for the longest time she was the
face of hololive
especially like early 2020s she was
internationally yeah internationally she
was the face and now it's kind of like
it's becoming a new kind of scene now so
it's interesting
it's going to be interesting to see how
the scene develops there's just so many
interesting
things that are that happen and
challenges that will come up
in that kind of space as opposed to
normal youtubing and twitch yeah yeah i
just
i cause we live this job right so i'm
just fascinated
by how a company would deal or how it
would tackle some of those those changes
that's what i find most interesting
about it it's you know i just love
seeing the scene it's such an interest
it's like this is the first time and
probably
god knows and we'll see this again where
a whole kind of genre is just popped up
very quickly yeah and explodes and is
very self-contained
because normally everything's
self-contained i think it's the most
self-contained we've seen out of
any genre on online well i think
hololive is
obviously definitely very self-contained
by you know by design
but i feel like v-tubing as a whole is
now kind of like
especially with the amount of youtubers
that have popped up on twitch and every
other streaming platform yeah
no it's not so much but yeah i guess it
was interesting at the time i think it's
everyone's just doing everything now but
yeah yeah i think it's still
self-contained
in a sense because like yeah you have a
lot more like individual youtubers now
doing things with other individual
youtube youtubers and you know youtubers
and agencies and stuff like that but at
the end of the day
if you yourself also aren't a v tuber
it's very difficult to do anything
with those kinds of people more
difficult than i'd say you know like if
i wanted to collab with like another
youtuber i don't know i think it's just
humor thing really if you have the same
kind of
content-ish aimed at the same audience
kind of thing it's doable i think
i don't know yeah